zachary est un professionnel des joutes
équestres chez lui en angleterre ces
disciplines est très prisé il est venu
renforcer la troupe de la chevalerie
initiatique comme tous les chevaliers il
a besoin des deux pour enfiler son
armure et ses multiples éléments
on a besoin en général de au moins une
personne mais souvent c'était deux
écuyers ou pages donc des jeunes et dans
qui venaient de familles d'autres
familles que de celle du du chevalier
d'habitude après une demi-heure
d'habillage voici zachary enfin près son
casque est plus lourd que l'armure mais
il paraît que c'est confortable c'est
très excitant l'adrénaline le coeur bat
très vite tu devais faire ça avec la
foule autour est vraiment très drôle
les joutes peuvent commencer une équipe
dans joue contre une équipe de touraine
qui se sont réellement affronter ici en
446 un quart d'heure de jeu pour tester
ses capacités et son adresse
puis 15 minutes de face à face à lens
briser l' objectif prouver sa valeur en
brisant sa lance sur le bouclier placé
sur l'épaule gauche d'adversaires sommes
tous très bien joué
the keys ont fait une belle compétition
il y en a
j'ai à nous et parce qu'il sait tout en
2d ex-aequo dans leur langue et c'est
mon show voyez préfet djia gagné j'adore
une maxi ses piques reparler
ils ont bien joué ils ont fait une belle
bataille
est ce que tu aimerais être un chevalier
toi pourquoi lorsque les chevals y sont
très forts depuis neuf ans le château du
rivau propose ce voyage à la fin du
moyen-âge
ce week-end près de 2500 personnes sont
venues applaudir les preux chevalier
aussi lourd de sart mur